former Vice President Joe Biden is
stepping up his campaign for medical
cause that is very deeply personal for
him he outlines his nonprofit cancer
initiative at the fortune brainstorm
health conference last night in San
Diego our dr. David agus set on the
initiative sits on the initiatives board
and moderated the conversation by his
oldest son Beau died of cancer two years
ago he shared with dr. Edith the
significant impact he fears that budget
cuts could have on critical research you
got to be able to do something to give
some people some hope to have a have a
shot speaking before some of the top
leaders in the biotech and health
industry Vice President Joe Biden
stressed the role of the government in
scientific research there is a point
that comes usually later than sooner
when the congressional party of the
president works up the courage to
challenge him he took aim at President
Trump's proposal to slash billions from
science and environmental agencies
pointing out that even members of mr.
Trump's own party spoke out against the
cuts
I think our Republican colleagues have
decided there are certain things are
just not negotiable and I think the
science the EPA I mean the idea the idea
that we're getting the proposals that
gut the EPA I mean come on for Christ
for gosh sakes you know NOAA members
just it's just bizarre how are we gonna
get the next young generation excited to
make a difference here I think they are
excited now I started you're starting to
see a rising tide of considerable rising
tide but what worries me is that you
know if we just for one or two years
make significant cuts we'll lose a whole
generation of young people who would
have moved and migrated to the area of
dealing with anything from Alzheimer's
that cancer whatever so it matters
obviously 2020 is not that far away
would you consider and I know the answer
is no no no but would you consider you
know going back in the Rings I have the
bad habit of answering questions and
I'll be completely honest with you I had
planned on running for president before
beau was diagnosed now the elections
over Donald Trump is president and I'm
disappointed to state the obvious but it
was the right decision for me not to run
and um I don't plan on running but
everybody says because I won't commit
that I will not run under any
circumstance that must mean I'm running
I'm doing nothing to run doctor Hagar's
joins us now from San Diego good morning
morning Charlie so when the vice
president answered that question what
was your sense of what he intends to do
you know I mean he has a intent right
now to make a difference he's going to
work on his diplomatic issues
particularly some world issues and
especially on his cancer initiative but
I could see in his eye and we had talked
before we went on stage I mean that he's
considering it and you know obviously
there's a passion there and there's a
humbleness there when he spoke there
wasn't a dry eye in the room you really
saw people leaning forward and listening
what's achievable in the next five years
in the next five years the hope is they
can accelerate clinical trials data
sharing just in this one year that he
was doing his initiative there have been
20 different government agencies that
are sharing data and working together
and that hadn't happened before so
there's going to be new progress he's
put together people to make that happen
break down barriers so that the advances
in cancer can move forward all right dr.
David agus we thank you for joining us
this morning thanks a lot